okay we've talked about settling on the
moon
on mars and
even venus but
how about
somewhere that's cold
dark and
smells like farts
yeah uranus yeah i mean uranus
what would conditions be like on this
ice giant
what kind of settlement would you need
to build
and what dangers would you encounter on
the stinkiest place in the solar system
this is what f and here's what would
happen if you lived on uranus
welcome to your new home on the seventh
planet from the sun
you'd now be a whopping 2.9
billion kilometers away
from our solar system's energy source
following in the footsteps of nasa's
voyager 2 probe
the journey to uranus would take about
nine and a half years but
now that you've made it
you'd catch a great view of this ice
giant
what you'd find is a planet four times
wider than the earth
orbited by 27 known moons and
13 rings
plus it would be rotating east to west
and
tipped on its side
well it's about time you head down to
the surface
wait
where's the surface
as you descend
hold your nose
this place stinks
the gassy atmosphere of uranus is
primarily made up of hydrogen helium and
methane
the higher altitudes would be the
smelliest thanks to the pungent rotten
egg smell of hydrogen sulfide
going further down toward the planet's
surface
you'd start to notice
there isn't one
uranus is smaller and compositionally
different than the gas giants jupiter
and saturn
it consists of slushy water methane and
ammonia fluids above a small rocky
center
not that you'd be able to see very much
uranus only receives about
0.27 percent as much sunlight as the
earth
so
you'd be living in darkness
with the lack of sunlight and surface
you couldn't grow your own food there
your ship would need to supply you with
food
but you could source your water from the
planet's water ice
you'd find conditions on the planet very
cold and windy
temperatures in some parts of the
atmosphere could be as low as minus
225 degrees
that's colder than neptune the outermost
planet in the solar system
massive clouds of ammonia and methane
ice crystals would swirl around you
storms almost two-thirds the size of the
united states would batter you with wind
speeds up to 900 kilometers per hour
but it's too late to turn back now
you'd need to learn how to settle and
survive in these conditions
establishing yourself on the surface
would be a definite no-go and the
strongest most frigid winds would tear
you apart in the lower altitudes
your best bet would be a floating
settlement up high in the clouds
but this wouldn't be your average blimp
or airship settlement
blimps only lift when inflated with a
gas that's lighter than the surrounding
atmosphere
on earth you'd use helium
on uranus there wouldn't be any lighter
gas to use
that's due to the atmosphere made of
molecular hydrogen and atomic helium
however you could try something more
theoretical
like a near vacuum ship
instead of gas this kind of ship would
create a vacuum to lift
you'd simply remove gas or add it to
allow the ship to go higher or lower
and it would be a clean technology no
fuel needed
you should get comfy because you'd never
be able to leave your ship without your
space suit
on uranus
you couldn't breathe
and you couldn't survive a second in the
unbelievably frigid temperatures
just stay safe and enjoy the view
okay now that you've figured out how to
survive
what would life on uranus be like
well for starters you'd find a slightly
different sense of gravity than you're
used to
but considering that uranus is 15 times
more massive than earth
you'd be surprised by the difference
contrary to what you might think you
wouldn't have to worry about being
crushed the surface gravity would be
only 90 percent as strong as the earth's
so if you weighed 75 kilograms on earth
you'd now be a lighter 67
kilograms another thing you'd have to
get used to is time
one uranian day would be equal to about
17 hours on earth
that wouldn't be so bad but
get ready for one incredibly long trip
around the sun
one year on uranus would equal 84 earth
years
yeah you could die of old age before the
year is over
you could even live an entire life in
just one
42-year long summer
or winter
a nice long summer on earth sounds
pretty good right about now
maybe it's time we tilted the earth
sideways on its axis to see what would
happen
but that sounds like a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you